you don't know them you don't see them
but they're always around
whispering making secret plans building
armies with millions of soldiers and
when they decide to attack they all
attack at the same time I'm talking
about bacteria who did you think I was
talking about bacteria living
communities just like humans they have
families they talk and they plan their
activities and just like humans they
trick the sieve and some might even
cheat on each other what if I tell you
that we can listen to bacterial
conversations and translate their
confidential information into human
language and what if I tell you that
translating bacterial conversations can
save lives
I also PhD in nano physics and I've used
nanotechnology to develop a real-time
translation tool that can spy on
bacterial communities and give us
recordings of what bacteria are up to
bacteria look everywhere there in the
soil and our furniture and inside our
bodies in fact 90% of all the life cells
in this theater are bacterial some
bacteria are good for us they help us
digest food or produce antibiotics and
some bacteria are bad for us they cause
diseases and death to coordinate all the
functions bacteria have they have to be
able to organize and they do that just
like us humans by communicating but
instead of using words they use
signaling molecules to communicate with
each other when bacteria are few the
signaling molecules just flow away like
the screams of a man alone in the desert
but when there are many bacteria the
signaling molecules accumulate and the
bacteria starts sensing that they're not
alone they listen to each other
in this way they keep track of how many
they are and when they are many enough
to initiate a new action and when the
signaling molecules have reached a
certain threshold all the bacteria sends
at once that they need to act with the
same action so bacterial conversation
consists of an initiative and a reaction
a production of a molecule and the
response to it and my research are
focused on spying on bacterial
communities inside the human body how
does it work we have a sample from a
patient it could be a blood or spit
sample we shoot electrons into the
sample the electrons will interact with
any communication molecules present and
this interaction will give us
information on the identity of the
bacteria the type of communication and
how much the bacteria are talking but
what is it like when bacteria
communicate before I developed this
translation the translation tool my
first assumption was that bacteria would
have a primitive language like infants
that haven't developed words and
sentences yet when they laugh they're
happy when they cry they're set simple
as that but bacteria turned out to be
nowhere as primitive as I thought they
would be a molecule is not just a
molecule it can mean different things
depending on the context just like the
crying of babies can mean different
things sometimes the baby is hungry
sometimes it's wet sometimes it's hurt
or afraid parents know how to decode
those cries and to be a real translation
tool it had to be able to decode the
signaling molecules and translate them
and translate them depending on the
context and who knows maybe Google
Translate will adapt this soon
let me give you an example I've brought
some bacterial data they can be a bit
tricky to understand if you're not
trained but try to take a look here is a
heavy bacterial family that has infected
a patient let's call them the Montague
family they share resources they
represent a they get a new neighbour
bacterial family Capulet everything is
fine as long as they're working together
but then something unplanned happens
Romeo from months ago has a relationship
with Juliet from Capulet and yes they
share genetic material now this Dean
transfer can be dangerous to the months
accused that have the ambition to be the
only family in the patient they have
infected and sharing genes contributes
to the Capulets developing resistance
antibiotics so the months accused are
talking internally to get rid of this
other family by releasing this molecule
and with subtitles let's coordinate an
attack and then everybody at once
respond by releasing a poison that will
kill the other family the Capulets
respond by calling for a counter-attack
and they have a pebble this is a video
of real bacteria dueling with sword like
organelles where they try to kill each
other by literally stepping and
rupturing each other whoever family wins
this battle becomes the dominant
bacteria so what I can do is to detect
bacterial conversations that lead to
different collective behaviors like the
fight you just saw and what I did was to
spy on bacterial communities inside the
human body in patients at a hospital I
followed 62 patients in an experiment
where I tested the patient samples for
one particular infection without knowing
the results of the traditional
diagnostic test now in bacterial
Diagnostics a sample is smeared out on a
plate and if the bacteria grow within
five days the patient is diagnosed as
infected when I finished the study and I
compared the tool results to the
traditional diagnostic tests and the
validation test I was shocked
it was far more astonishing than I had
ever anticipated but before I tell you
what the tool revealed I'd like to tell
you about a specific patient I followed
a young girl she had cystic fibrosis a
genetic disease that made her lung
susceptible to bacterial infections this
girl wasn't a part of the clinical trial
I followed her because I knew from her
medical record that she had never had an
infection before once a month this girl
went to the hospital to cough our best
butum sample that she spit in a cup this
sample was transferred for bacterial
analysis at the central laboratory so
the doctors could act quickly if they
discovered an infection
and it allowed me to test my device on
her cymbals as well the first two months
I measured on her samples there was
nothing but the third month I discovered
some bacterial cheddar in her sample the
bacteria were coordinating to damage her
lung tissue but the trip but but the
traditional Diagnostics showed no
bacteria at all i measured again the
next month and i could see that the
bacterial conversations became even more
aggressive still the traditional
Diagnostics showed nothing my study
ended about half a year later I followed
up on her status to see if the bacteria
only I knew about had disappeared
without medical intervention they hadn't
but the girl was now diagnosed with a
severe infection of deadly bacteria it
was the very same bacteria mites all
discovered earlier and despite
aggressive antibiotic treatment it was
impossible to eradicate the infection
doctors deemed that she would not
survive her 20s when I measured on this
girl samples my tool was still in the
initial stage I didn't even know if my
method worked at all therefore I had an
agreement with the doctors not to tell
them what my tool revealed in order not
to compromise their treatment so when I
saw these results that weren't even
validated I didn't dare to tell because
treating a patient without an actual
infection also has negative consequences
for the patient but now we know better
and there are many young boys and girls
that still can be saved because
unfortunately this scenario happens very
often patients get infected the bacteria
somehow don't show on the traditional
diagnostic test and suddenly the
infection breaks out in the patient with
severe symptoms and at that point it's
already too late
the surprising the result of the
sixty-two patients I followed was that
my device caught bacterial conversations
and more than half of the patient
samples that were diagnosed as negative
by traditional methods in other words
more than half of these patient went
home thinking they were free from
infection although they actually carried
dangerous
seria side these wrongly diagnosed
patients bacteria were coordinating a
synchronized attack they were whispering
to each other what I call whispering
bacteria are bacteria that traditional
methods cannot diagnose so far it's only
the translation tool that can catch
those whispers I believe that the
timeframe in which bacteria are still
whispering is a window of opportunity
for targeted treatment if the girl had
been treated during this window of
opportunity it might have been possible
to kill the bacteria in their initial
stage before the infection got out of
hand what I experienced with this young
girl made me decide to do everything I
can to push this technology into the
hospital together with doctors I'm
already working on implementing this
tool in clinics to diagnose early
infections although it's still not known
how doctors should treat patients during
the whispering face this tool can help
doctors keep a closer eye on patients
and risk it could help them confirm if a
treatment had worked or not and it could
help answering simple questions is the
patient infected and what are the
bacteria up to bacteria talk they make
secret plans and they send confidential
information to each other but not only
can we catch them whispering we can all
learn their secret language and become
ourselves bacterial whisperers and as
bacteria would say 3ox oc12 and a line
[Music]